let's explore
the scientific
scientific
method
which at first might seem a little bit
intimidating but when we walk through it
you'll see that it's actually
almost a common sense way of looking at
the world and making progress in our
understanding of the world and feeling
good about that progress of our
understanding of the world
so let's just use a tangible example
here and we'll walk through what we
could consider
the steps of the scientific method
you'll see different steps articulated
in different ways but they all boil down
to the same thing you observe something
about reality and you say well let me
let me try to come up with a a a reason
for why that observation happens and
then you try to test that explanation
it's very important that you come up
with explanations that you can test and
then you can see if they're true and
then based on whether they're true you
keep you keep iterating if it's not true
you try to come up with another
explanation if it is true but it doesn't
explain everything well once again you
try to explain more of it
so as a tangible as a tangible example
let's say that you live in in i don't
know northern canada or something and
let's say you live near the beach but
there's also a pond near your house
and you notice that the pond tends to
freeze over sooner in the winter than
than the ocean does it does that faster
and even does it at higher temperatures
than when the ocean seems to freeze over
so you could view that as your
observation so the first step is you're
making an observation
observation
in our particular case it's that the
pond freezes over at higher temperatures
than the ocean does and it freezes over
sooner in the winter
well the next question you might want to
or the next step you could use a
scientific method it doesn't have to be
this regimented but this is a structured
way of thinking about it as well ask
yourself a question
ask
ask a question
why
does so in this particular question or
in this particular scenario why does the
pond tend to freeze over faster and at
higher temperatures than the ocean does
well you then try to answer that
question and this is a key part of the
scientific method is what you do in this
third step is that you try to create an
explanation but what's key is that it is
a testable explanation
so you try to
you create a testable
explanation
testable explanation and this is kind of
the core one of the core pillars of the
scientific method and this testable
explanation is called your hypothesis
your
hypothesis and so in this particular
case a testable explanation could be
that
well the ocean is made up of salt water
and this pond is fresh water so your
testable explanation could be
salt water
salt
water
has lower freezing point
has lower
freezing
point
lower freezing point so it takes colder
temperatures to freeze it then
then fresh water
so this right over here this would be a
good hypothesis it doesn't matter
whether the hypothesis is actually true
or not we haven't actually run the
experiment but it's a good one because
we can construct an experiment that
tests this very well now what would be
an example of a bad hypothesis or
something that you couldn't even
necessarily consider as part of the
scientific method well you could say
that
i there's a there is a fairy
fairy that blesses
that let's say that performs magic
performs
magic
on the pond
pond
to freeze it faster
freeze
it
faster
and
the reason why this isn't so good is
that this is not so testable because
it's depending on this fairy and you
don't know how to convince the fairy to
try to do it again you haven't seen the
fair you haven't observed the fairy it's
not based on any observation and so this
one right over here this would not be a
good a good hypothesis for the
scientific method so we would want to
rule that one out so let's go back to
our testable explanation our hypothesis
salt water has a lower freezing point
than fresh water well the next step the
next step would be to
to make a prediction based on that and
this is the part where we're really
designing an experiment
so you could just view all of this as
designing let me just in a different
color
where we want to design an experiment
design
and experiment
and in that experiment let's say and
let's see the next two steps i will i'll
put as part of this
as part of this experimental
whoops i messed up let me
i did my undo step so the next part that
i will do is the experiment
experiment
and
there you go so the first thing is we'll
say i take i i you know there's all
sorts of things that are going on
outside the ocean has waves um you know
maybe there are boats going by that
might potentially break up the ice so i
want to i just want wanna isolate that
one variable that i care about whether
something is salt water or not and i
wanna control for everything else so i
wanna control for whether
there's waves or not or whether there's
wind or any other possible explanation
for why the pond freezes over faster so
what i do in a very controlled
environment i get i take two cups
i take two cups that's one cup
and two cups and i put water in those
cups
i put water in those cups
and let's say i start with distilled
water but then this one stays
this first one right over here stays
distilled and still means that through
evaporation i've taken out all of the
impurities of that water and in the
second one i take
i take that distilled water and i throw
a bunch of salt in it so this one is
fresh very fresh
in fact far fresher than what you would
find in a pot it's distilled water and
then this is this is over here this is
salt water
so you wouldn't see the salt but just
for our visuals you depict it and then
we would make a prediction we'd make a
prediction we could even view this as
step four
our prediction
we predict
that the fresh water will freeze at a
higher temperature than the salt water
so what prediction let's say
the fresh freezes
fresh
freezes
at
zero degrees zero degrees celsius
but
salt doesn't
salt water doesn't salt
whoop not sat
salt
water
doesn't
so what you then do is that you test
your prediction so then you test it and
how would you test it well you could
have a very accurate freezer that is
exactly at zero degrees celsius and you
put both of these both of these cups
into it and you want to make sure that
they're identical and everything where
you control for everything else you
control for the surface area you control
for the material of the glass you
control for how much water there is but
then you test it
and then you see what happened from your
test
you leave it in overnight and if you see
that the fresh water has frozen over so
it's frozen over but the salt water
hasn't well then that seems to validate
that seems to validate your testable
explanation that salt water has a lower
freezing point than fresh water and and
if it didn't freeze well it's like okay
well that may be that that or if there
isn't a difference maybe either both of
them didn't freeze or both of them did
freeze then you might say well okay that
that wasn't a good explanation i have to
find another explanation for why the
ocean seems to freeze at a lower
temperature or you might say well that's
part of the explanation but that by
itself doesn't explain it or you might
now want to ask even further questions
well when does salt water freeze and
what else is dependent on do the waves
have an impact do the does the wind have
an impact and so then you can you can go
into the process of iterating and
refining so
you then
refine
and iterate on the process when i'm
talking about iterate you're doing it
over again but then based on the things
that you've learned and so you might
come up with a more refined testable
explanation or you might come up with
more experiments that could get you a
better understanding of the difference
between fresh and salt water you might
try to come up with experiments for why
exactly what is it about the salt that
makes this this water harder to freeze
so that's essentially the essence of the
scientific method and i want to
emphasize this isn't some you know
bizarre thing this is this is this is
logical reasoning make a testable
explanation for something that you're
observing in the world and then you test
it and you see if your explanation seems
to hold up based on the data from your
test and then whether or not it holds up
you then keep going and you keep
refining and you keep learning more
about the world and the reason why this
is better than just saying oh well look
okay i see the pond has frozen over and
the ocean hasn't it must be the salt
water and you know i just feel good
about that is that you can't feel good
about that there's a there's a million
different reasons and you shouldn't just
go on your gut because at some point
your gut might be right ninety percent
of the time but that ten percent that
it's wrong you're going to be you're
going to be passing on knowledge or or
assumptions about the world that aren't
true and then other people are going to
build on that and then our all of our
knowledge is going to build be built on
kind of a shaky foundation and so the
scientific method ensures that our
foundation is strong
and i'll leave you with the gentleman
who's often considered to be the father
or one of the fathers of the scientific
method he lived in cairo and in what is
now iraq oh nearly a thousand or roughly
a thousand years ago
and he was famous astronomer and and
physicist and mathematician and his
quote is a pretty powerful one because i
think it even stands today
the duty of the man who investigates the
writings of scientists if learning is
the if learning the truth is his goal
let me start over just so i get the
dramatic effect right the duty of the
man who investigates the writings of
scientists if learning the truth is his
goal is to make himself an enemy of all
that he reads
and attack it from every side he should
also suspect himself as he performs his
critical examination of it so that he
may avoid falling into either prejudice
or leniency hassan ibn al-haytham and
his latinized name is al-hazen so he's
saying be skeptical and not just
skeptical of what other people write and
read but even of yourself and another
aspect of the scientific method which is
super important is if someone says they
made a hypothesis and they tested and
they got a result in order for that to
be a good test and in order for that to
be a good hypothesis that experiment has
to be reproducible someone can't say oh
it's only you know a certain time that
only happens once every 100 years and
not that that's why it happened that day
it has to be reproducible and
reproducible is key because then another
skeptical scientist like yourself can
say let me see if i can reproduce it let
me see let me not just believe it
because that person looks like they're
smart and they said that it is true